[Music]
okay we got black again
all right so
i think it's time for us to vary our
openings a little bit let's go knight f6
and see what we can do
all right so i've been introducing you
guys to some relatively offbeat openings
i'm i'm thinking of maybe playing a
budapest gambit since it's late in the
night and
i feel uh i feel like experimenting a
little bit let's play a budapest
now this is called the budapest gambit
okay e3 and unfortunately our opponent
declines it
but the funny thing is if your opponent
declines the budapest then black is
already like playing for an advantage
in this position black is already
playing for an advantage and you can do
this in several ways you can play e
takes d4 and d5 or you can get your
knight out to c6 first
and this essentially is already
i would already take black here we have
a lead in development we have a good
center
and um
okay so so where should the night go
here this is already an important moment
and if even if you've been watching the
previous game you should know where i
like to put my knight in such a
situation
yeah so 97 knight g6 this is the my
preferred maneuver is almost always 97
knight g6
and get the knight to g6 quickly so that
you can get your bishop out
okay so where should the bishop go well
you can go to c5 even though it's biting
on granite it's still fine i mean it's
still a developing move you can
absolutely go bishop b7 and d6 a modest
modest developing move nothing wrong
with that
or you could go bishop b4
so there's many ways that we can develop
our pieces here
i actually kind of like the look of
bishop c5
because
this is a good chance to illustrate
potential energy right you might look at
this and say i don't get this move at
all it's just staring at the pawn but if
white ever plays the move e4 which is
not unlikely what if white wants to
develop his own bishop
white's maybe gonna play e4 and then the
bishop's really going to come alive
so we're making a long-term investment
let's go d6 obviously
this is a classic example of potential
energy and in fact i would even play the
london move okay so especially now
since b4
is an idea we can stop b4 with a5 or we
can play a6 to create look for the
bishop on a7 and what i want to show you
guys that b4 is not scary just because
white's played b4 doesn't mean we're
lost this bishop is just as good on a7
as it was on c5 in fact i would even say
that it's better and white's not playing
c5 anytime soon we've got that square
under control queen c2 white's playing
well though i have to say
okay well d6 prepares to develop the
bishop so that's just a movie play in
these types of positions all right let's
go let's go ricky hey let's get this
rook onto an open a semi-open file may
be preparing you for in some positions
and i'm really trying to provoke white
into playing e4 which is a move i think
most 1700s would be inclined to play
not a terrible move by any stretch but
not a great one because that really
justifies our positioning of the bishop
so it's almost like a standoff here 92
another great move
now i think we should start attacking
now i think we should start attacking
and it's very hard to attack in these
kinds of positions where your opponent
is a very solid structure
um you you have to know certain
maneuvers and ideas that are not
elementary so i'm going to play the move
knight g4
you might think that the idea is to play
queen h4 it partially is
but more um specifically i'm actually
trying to get this knight back around to
h6
who can explain to me why what is the
significance of this maneuver knight g4
h3 knight h6 i'm also trying to provoke
h3
which would act as a hook for maybe a
later bishop sacrifice on h3
to push up because you're crazy yeah to
push f5 we want to push this pawn
and and drive drive the pawns up into
white's position
and the knight you might say well isn't
the knight bad well the knight is giving
itself up for the greater good for the
time being and it's not like the knight
is permanently going to be on h6 it can
later
it has a lot of mobility
this is a um
a pretty well known idea in a bunch of
different variations
the other thing that we're doing is is
giving our queen a path to the king side
so under a certain set of circumstances
we might want to play queen g5 or queen
h4 and set up maybe a bishop sacrifice
on h3 depending on how white positions
their pieces knight b3 okay
so this actually is probably a great
time to go queen h4
because we haven't gone f5 yet so we
still have this diagonal open for our
bishop and because the knight has moved
away from d2 the significance of that
is that um
when the knight was on d2 the move queen
h4 could have always been met with
knight f3 attacking the queen chasing it
away
here the queen on h4 is actually quite
safe it cannot be attacked by anything
for the time being since g3 drops the
pawn on h3 so we're just getting our
queen into the attack here and white's
doing a great job i mean he's preparing
c5 he's playing this like a professional
but i still feel like our attack is
going to be stronger here
queen g5 is also good yeah queen g5 is
also good but i think queen g5 might run
into 94. that's the only difference
i feel like queen on h4 is really really
nicely positioned and we're already
thinking about bishop takes h3
very very much on the table as is f5 f5
is still on the table there's nothing
nothing happened to f5
yeah and it's it's hard to play these
positions for both sides you've got to
know the ideas you got to know what to
do
okay c5 great great stuff by our
opponent
so
there's a very subtle difference
between this position and the previous
one
if we think about sacking we're not
going to stack we're going to play f5
the reason i don't want to sack
is because after
bishop takes h3 gh queen takes h3
what
very annoying defensive move
does white have in that position and i
feel like that defensive move allows
white to bring pieces into the defense i
just don't think we have enough
firepower there i don't think we have
enough firepower in that position white
plays the move f3
white plays the move f3
two ideas the main idea is to get this
queen into the defense along the second
rank
the second is to prevent this knight on
h6 from jumping into the game with
knight h with knight g4
so we're gonna go with our old idea and
play f5
now you might
be saying to this but now i don't
understand the consistency isn't this
inconsistent right we put a queen on h4
and now all of a sudden we're covering
up the diagonal well i have two things
to say to that the first is that we're
not abandoning the general idea of
sacking on h3 we might still go f4 and
reopen this possibility the second thing
is that the queen on h4 is good as a
standalone piece it it's not just
preparing bishop takes issue we're also
just chilling on the king side in case
the king's side opens up our queen is
going to be well positioned right
so queen h4 is just a good flexible move
white on the other hand is not making
much progress on the on the queen side
if you think about it our structure is
very solid here knight b5 is not
possible part of the reason that our
pawn is on a6 is to prevent knight b5 so
it's going to be very difficult for
white to to make progress on the queen
side without opening up our bishop back
up with c takes d6
queen e2
okay
so
now we have to decide which pawn we're
going to push
i personally like to start with e4 but
the drawback of e4 is that it does give
away the d4 square which could
potentially be a little bit annoying
on the other hand e4 gets us the e5
square for our knight
the other candidate move here is to go
f4 which i also really like
so i like both moves but we're gonna
stick with our original plan and go e4
and now we're going to stick
this knight into the center with knight
e5
and f4 by the way is still very much on
the table we might still go f4 and
sacrifice this bond and then just start
throwing our pieces up white bishop b2
all right now we need to assemble more
pieces we need more beef on the king's
side what are we missing what are we
missing in this attack well think about
it
what piece would you like to have in the
attack we could go g5 g4 here that's one
possibility but i want to attack with
our pieces i want our goddamn rook to
actually do something was just sitting
there on e8 and doing nothing let's get
it into the action with rook f6 rook g6
and yes this is a little bit slow this
is a three move idea but remember that
the center is pretty close so it's not
like
we're in
you know a ridiculous rush but white is
playing super well knight d4 f4 that's a
high level idea
i was to be completely not expecting to
find it now the only thing what is the
drawback of knight d4
what is the drawback of knight d4 what
does it allow
what does it allow
well let's think about what it leaves
undefended
don't just look at the king's side don't
get tunnel vision on the king side it
allows us to get this bishop back into
the game at long last 96 though jeez
okay
let me think about this for a second i
have an idea let's let's take that god
knight out of the way
okay now
i have a pretty crazy idea here guys i'm
just going to play it in the interest of
time
i'm going to make the move pawn to c6
this is a multi-purpose move the first
idea is to prevent white snipe from
jumping into the center with knight b5
but there is a secondary idea now notice
this pin right white is threatening e7
let's get this the heck out of g8 with
king h8
yeah bishop b8 i want to go bishop b8
and then i want to throw my knight onto
f3 and sacrifice it in order to shatter
open white's king position
but how do i want to do this let me
think this guy is really really good i'm
going to be honest he's really really
good
we're going to do it now let's go knight
f3 let's get this okay takes immediately
okay queen takes h3
maybe i miscalculated here but
i thought this was good
yeah no the white is playing this very
very well but i think this is still good
for us i i don't know
there is something i realized i missed
oh my god but we have a beautiful idea
holy smoke there's an amazing line here
there's multiple amazing lines bishop b5
oh my god that's a blunder
that's a terrible blunder by white
i hope you guys haven't forgotten that
we were threatening this all along he
takes f3 and there's mate why does to
give up their his queen
hope you haven't forgotten about that
move
wow that was close i actually was
calculating wow that's a total
total meltdown
that's a quite the meltdown we should
definitely analyze the computer here
because i definitely made a lot of
mistakes there
if if that's okay we're going to skip
the opening we're going to go straight
into analyzing with an engine and i'm
going to try to reveal some of the cool
lines that i was looking at toward the
end
he's obviously not cheating and when i
compliment somebody and say they're
playing well i'm i really am not
trying to imply automatically that our
opponent is cheating
i'm really not
okay
so
we're just gonna fast forward here
okay queen h4
f5 is interesting about b6 apparently
was good
look at that move b6
i mean the the point is that you're
trying to induce c6 and then eventually
you'll have b5 to open up this bishop
but basically okay f5 is fine
our accuracy was 88 e4 is best 95 is
best
rook f8 is not great apparently knight
hf7 was best
with the idea i think of getting this
knight into the game via g5
maybe even g5 g4
rook f8 again i wouldn't necessarily
call this a blunder it takes it from
minus one to even which is
not great but
okay queen d1 who's playing that move
explain to me who is playing queen e2 to
d1 and this i don't even understand the
point of that
that is a ridiculous move
so
dc is best knight e6 now this is
actually very high level and c6 is a
really bad move i blundered here oh
oh my god i see what i blundered
so we were supposed to play c4
with the idea of getting this knight to
d3 which i saw but i thought this allows
knight d5
but apparently after knight d3 the
position still very unclear
bishop d3 cd queen e1 this is a complete
mess complete mess
so we have this incredibly monster pawn
on d3 but white has a ton of stuff in
the center as well the queen's coming to
c3 with a battery so i saw this line and
that's why i played c6 i tried to
prevent knight d5
but i blundered the fact that white has
an x-ray against this knight and there's
this move knight takes e4
knight takes e4
opening up the attack on the bishop on
the knight
and the problem is that black's attack
runs completely out of steam here
white's king side is completely intact
and now black's pieces just look
terrible and white has this pawn on e6
which he's going to keep alive
so i i just i only thought about knight
d5 here
which um which is not that good because
of knight f3 check but knight takes c4
is really strong because it prevents
knight f3 it takes the sting out of it
because there's no longer an anchor pawn
does that make sense so knight takes e4
this was a move that was miss bishop b3
was a mistake
king h8 knight f3 check is very good
and now i'm going to show you guys the
cool line so
if f4
we go
oh my god look at this line rook f6 this
is what i saw rook f6
now we're lifting a rook up to g6 right
does that move make sense but it looks
like a blunder
bishop takes f6
and that's the point we play g takes f6
opening up the g file for our other rook
but that's not the end of the story why
can play the move e7 in order to secure
that square with his bishop bishop g8
so you might be looking in this position
and saying wait a second isn't knight g4
checkmate and it's important to
understand why it's not it's not because
white plays f3 this is a move you should
be familiar with i mentioned it
previously and at best this is a draw
but remember that whole potential energy
thing remember that whole potential
energy thing with a bishop
try this move on c4
okay we're threatening rook g8 white has
to take it and now after knight g4 the
bishop finally gets into the game and if
white plays f3
this leads to checkmate bishop takes e3
check
and queen h2 mate or rook f2 queen h2
and queen h1
c frickin 4
opening up the bishop that's how you
attack yeah amazing line look at this
line f4
so you start with rook f6
you start with the rook f6
um sorry you start with work f6 to get
the stroke to g6 in order to open the g
file this idea i've seen before
but after e7 c4 is simply amazing to
open up the bishop which doesn't come
into play until you go knight c4
inducing f3
so i think everybody
was able to follow the line
now f takes e4 is an alternative and
here again we play c4
it's the same exact idea we go knight g4
and because of the mate threat
white loses because white can't play f3
amazing amazing concept and here we're
winning
here we're winning white apparently can
go f takes e4 and then f3 and give up
the bishop but you can see it's
basically still lost for white the
attack is overwhelming
yeah no this is great
and and so knight f3 was the correct
move but this was set up by a big big
tactical error which is the blunder
knight takes e4
yeah bishop b3 is a mistake but a very
natural move to prepare e7 and and why
does knight take c4 no longer work
because now there's queen takes e4 and
there used to be a bishop on c2 that was
preventing this from pot from happening
f3 and there's queen d3 very important
follow-up move
otherwise you lose this knight
so many cool ideas and i'm barely
scratching the surface there's so many
other lines here where like black goes
knight f3 but i'm really tired i i'm
gonna pause for today and maybe i'll
continue this analysis next time for
those watching on youtube i apologize
it's like
3 a.m so i'm going to cut this cut this
here but you guys are welcome to find
this in my game history dig around with
the engine
i think honestly that that's part of the
fun
um you can discover your own cool lines
you kind of have the general skeleton
right the general thoughts
and some of the some of the
highlight variations
all right guys i'm going to call it a
day i'm really tired um
but uh thank you everybody this was a
lot of fun i'll see you guys later thank
you so much for hanging out appreciate
the support
see you tomorrow
[Music]